un autre sport sans contact physique qui
demandent juste un peu de matériel une
boussole et une carte il s'agit de la
course d'orientation
un sport assez récents qui plaît aux
amoureux de la nature ce matin plus de
mille sportifs ont participé à une
épreuve nationale dans la forêt de
meudon
ils ont fait marcher la tête et les
jambes un reportage denis fermé et
france à quartier aux portes de paris
dans la forêt de meudon dernier grand
rendez vous pour les orienteurs ils sont
près de 14 cents au départ pour une
course individuelle et par équipe contre
la montre une carte aux dix millième une
boussole une tête et des jambes pour
passer des balises 7 enfantin même pour
un ancien champion de france j'ai pris
un peu d'âge et maintenant je cours dans
une catégorie supérieure
je peux encore le devenir pendant
beaucoup d'années puisqu'il ya
dekel catégorie h 40 h 45 à 50 et ainsi
de suite donc encore peut-être pendant
vingt ans la seo se dispute en terrain
varié forestier sur un circuit
matérialisé par des balises que le
coureur doit trouver par l'itinéraire de
son choix mais dans un ordre imposé on
sait dans de la carte restée secrète
jusqu'au départ le charme d'un chrono
notation c'est d'abord le contact avec
la nature bien entendu et puis le
plaisir la recherche de la balise pour
ceux qui le découvrent ensuite pour les
compétiteurs bien entendu c'est l'aspect
compétition et le fait d'affronter la
rudesse de la nature qui compte c'est un
sport qui ne coûtent pas cher puisque
l'achat du matériel est extrêmement
raide unis une boussole nous coûtera un
peu plus de 100 francs
l'achat des cartes le prix des cours je
représente très peu de choses l'île de
france 1re ligue du pays avec 17 clubs
et 700 licenciés et championne de france
des clubs 94 avec le cs lg melun et
olivier coupe à 280 numéro un français
remporte la coupe de france 95 ravi de
courir dans les hauts-de-seine
il faut varier les plaisirs on aime
j'aime autant courir dans le jura dans
le vercors dans le virage vers bordeaux
dans les landes qui si basse qu'il a
c'est sympa c'est que justement il ya un
peu cet aspect médiatique
on voit beaucoup de gens forêt donc on
espère que les gens vont se demander
tiens qu'est-ce que c'est alors si vous
êtes curieux venez rejoindre les fanas
de la course d'orientation un sport qui
ne perd pas le nord